so the voters don't believe her because
this is a you don't see what you
actually see liberal she's out there you
know she's a big government girl and
this has been her motto throughout by
the way for the last year and a half or
whatever it's been you don't see what's
actually happening you don't feel it
you're not really afraid to walk to the
grocery store and people are like no
actually I am so that's not going to be
a successful argument the problem in a
place like New York is that you have a
bunch of Voters and this happens in very
liberal cities oftentimes where they
will vote Democrat regardless you could
put Fidel Castro on the voting belt they
don't care it's like d oh he's back
that's oh yeah they won't care they will
they will
both sides absolutely do that the
problem is is that when she's the
problem you need someone to what you
need is a voter to say this stuff's not
working maybe I've always been a
lifelong Democrat maybe I support the
ideals of the party as they once were
this stuff is not for me what's more
important to me right now is my Safety
and Security and the Safety and Security
of my family end of story